hey there welcome to Conan O'Brien needs
a friend joined by Sona messian hey Sona
hi Matt gorley how are you sir Merry
Christmas well I was going to get to
that yeah you think I wouldn't get to
that uh it is I get I was I have to say
I do get the Christmas spirit I do every
year do you yeah are you
sick what I'm sorry I think it's I just
saw this DayQuil thing are you sick
sorry I thought it was because he had
the Christmas spirit and you're like
you're I got sick too after we got back
from New York okay that made no sense to
our listeners this is this is what our
listeners heard I have the Christmas
spirit are you sick that's what I heard
yeah that's what I heard too and you
just yeah I had a cold like I got a cold
like about a week ago I don't have it
anymore but I still take these okay uh
to just make my voice sound a little
better on air yeah um but uh I as as a
son of an infectious disease doctor no
easily 11 days after having a cold I'm a
threat to no one if that's your fear
that's I'm not I'm not I got sick too
that's why I was like hey we all got
well if you're sick you shouldn't have
come in okay um Merry Christmas everyone
it's literally Christmas Day when people
are listen what did I do Christmas I had
a nice Christmas thing and then I
started to say hey um you know I have
the Christmas spirit you're sick you
sick how dare you have the
Christmas spirit you pervert you pervert
what does that mean to you did you watch
some Christmas pervy porn
you sick well I was on your side
and now I'm wondering what did you
watch why do you have the Christmas
spirit because of Christmas pervy it's
Mrs Claus no stop don't do it don't do
it this is where she's got a slamming B
and then there's a knock at the door and
she thinks it's an elf but it's a pizza
delivery what are you and she's like I
expected an elf but I forgot that I
ordered a pizza and he says yeah extra
sausage and she says what I don't like
sausage and he said no that's double and
Tandra for dick and she's like no I just
don't like sausage and he said there's
no sausage Mrs
Claus that's the thing you say when
you're about to you
know take out the penis oh well just so
we're clear there's no there's no
sausage this is the worst porn I've ever
where is Santa is he out on his Mission
Santa is so sick of Mrs claw's
misunderstanding doubl and
Tandra that he just doesn't even much of
a life with her anymore okay I see cuz
he's whenever he's trying to be romantic
you know oh man yeah he's he'll like
just say some what some some harmless
double and Tandra like check out this
North Pole yeah check out this North
Pole and like we're at the North Pole
why would I have to check it out we live
here and he's like no no I'm telling you
Sandra that's Mrs Claus's real name is
it I'm no no no Sandra we haven't had
sex in a while and I thought maybe to
spice things up I'd say Che out this
North Pole but what do you mean we're at
the North no no I meant my blood
engorged
come on that's all I'm trying to
put some spice but wait a minute why did
you say North po because the pole is my
literal anatomical pole oh God damn it
Sandra I'm going back to the
workshop God I'm going to go a bird
house
well merry Christmas everybody Merry
Christmas Merry Christmas you old
savings and loan God bless us everyone
oh my God that gets people in the spirit
right there God now now listen I want to
understand something because uh I know
that is Christmas celebrated at a
different time of year in the Armenian
calendar yes well it's it's the Orthodox
Christmas which is January 6th what's
that mean exactly don't ask me yeah but
but what I would say oh okay I only know
this because you know Sona started
working for me and I was I think was
pretty nice I'd give you a nice
Christmas gift and I'd get nothing back
and she would say yeah I'll get you on
Armenian Christmas and I thought that
for a while that was an excuse like yeah
maybe I'll get you something maybe I
won't but then it turned out you always
did give me really nice gifts just later
on yeah it's better because you don't
have to deal with the Christmas rush and
then you have a lot of sales after deep
Christmas yeah so it it always worked
out and it gave me more time to do
things but we celebrate both oh you do
both that always used to make me I had
friends who would celebrate Hanukkah but
also Christmas and I thought oh come on
well as a Children of Divorce parents I
got two Christmases which you know was a
silver lining oh you'll be okay you seem
to turn out just fine did you're not a
weird guy at all okay no you seem fine I
thought maybe I was no no oh God no oh
God they'll get back together yeah sure
they will they'll get back together it's
literally been 4's a good healthy reason
why you spent a lot of your life working
at an amusement park this to create the
joy artificially that you couldn't
have it's so personal I'm at the
happiest place on Earth so I must be
happy any day now any day now here comes
my dad your dad is Goofy oh no my dad
did work at Disney though he met Walt
Disney did he really yeah what was that
like that's a cool story awesome yeah
but I'm a second generation Disney
employee okay don't worry about it
listen oh God help me it's it's fine I'm
sure you oh God please don't let my
daughter work
there she's working there now oh god oh
no she's just a baby um listen uh I uh
I'm what are you doing I'm just writing
rap for when it's time to rap you don't
I know but you wrote it ahead of time
also did you hear that did you hear him
writing I did hear the scri yeah when
you listen I haven't been in this
business long and you're Mr podcast and
you wrote with a well ballpoint pen on a
hard surface and it sounds like a that's
because when you're Mr podcast you're
not Mr radio and all rules are out the
window man it's a wild you can write on
a podcast you're going to leave that in
can edit it out no he's going to keep it
in because this is me busting him on you
threw me off I am a sorry an artist oh
God and this is my medium no I am now
you threw me off okay that's nice sorry
was that yours was that you're sleeping
I was snoring sorry I start I fell
asleep while you were talking about
being an artist okay yeah I I'm glad
you're awake now because as an
[Applause]
artist it will always make me laugh that
The Three Stooges snore in unison like
in synchronized
ways just I don't know it's just gold
and anyone who disagrees should never
judge comedy oh Sor um sorry Sona well I
didn't I didn't say I didn't like it why
you just well you didn't laugh but you
can laugh on Armenian Christmas well
okay oh my God no I like it too what are
your are your kids going to on the 25th
will Santa visit your kids yeah okay but
then he'll also show up on the does does
Santa show up on the six really show up
on
fig shows up no we we we we say we go to
church but we don't is there an Armenian
Santa no like a like a equivalent like a
g papa is it January 6 three King day
isn't that why don't ask me the specific
Armenians ask Eduardo knows better than
I do Eduardo is married to an Armenian
woman yeah and apparently one who cares
about the religion and the Heritage does
okay okay but tell us tell us what you
know well January 6 is Dia de well in
Spanish Dia the three kings that's when
they bring gifts yes the wise was that
when Jesus really got his gold
frankincense and myrr or something cor
correct okay many people say uh and many
conservatives say that what happened on
the capital on January 6th was just
people
celebrating don't connect it no no
listen that is a theory connect that
people were so whipped up about Armenian
Christmas that they wanted to they
wanted to gather together and
celebrate hey let's go into the capital
and hey the door's locked well we can
probably push it open r r let's push it
open R
it January 6 was an Armenian
H I hear those sleigh bells ringing and
Jing
Jing let's go back to Disneyland no
we're good hey uh man that was an insane
opening uh so stupid stupid but also in
its own way really stupid uh you are an
artist I am an
artist